all right so what's going on so
basically there's streaming wars going
on netflix disney hulu everybody's
fighting for subscribers okay well how
am i going to differentiate from if i'm
netflix how do i differentiate from hulu
and hbo and all this stuff basically
they need original content okay so
that's created this like huge imbalance
of there used to be a lot of content and
a small amount of distribution now
there's a lot of distribution fighting
for a small amount of content and all
the distribution players have just
decided like the prize is big let's lose
money for a lot of like several years
and invest billions into content and
like let's be the last person standing
and so they're they're investing on what
you call a j curve where the curve goes
down you lose a bunch of money and then
a j like a j it goes way up and you make
money later what that means for these
production companies is they'll overpay
there's a bidding war and they are
willing to overpay for my content
[Music]
all right in this episode we are talking
about the latest industry that i am
totally completely obsessed with i
almost can't think of anything else and
i'm not sure why other people aren't
freaking out about this so i go on a
rant about that what else we got we
talked about mark manson and uh how he's
got this amazing empire on this book
called the subtle art of not giving it
an f i'll say f there and how it started
just as a blog post and turned into this
amazing business that's making tens of
millions of dollars for for for him and
then we also talked about production
companies and how the breakdown is
actually way better than we thought you
know the the economics and how it works
is far more fascinating than we
anticipated
all right enjoy
all right we're live dude i'm in a
horrible mood and the bad part about
this job is like you have to like
immediately snap out of a horrible mood
and i can't exactly explain all the
details about why i'm in a bad mood but
basically
it involves like a real estate deal that
i did and someone i feel is trying to
take advantage of me and here's what i
think happens and tell me if this
happens to you i feel like
we i do a deal with someone or whether
it's like a small deal or a big deal and
then they like learn about what our
stupid podcast is named or they google
us but it's mostly the fact that the
podcast has such a horrible name and
then they like you know you get like you
know like in hawaii where they got like
the local price and they got the other
guy price it's like it's like i get the
other guy price you know what i mean and
uh if even if it's just a little of
another guy discrepancy it pisses me off
that's hilarious uh yeah i i don't think
that happens to me no one's ever ever
referenced it i've never got that
feeling in fact i actually get a bunch
of credit the other way people are like
look um you know i don't want to offend
you with like a lowball offer on your on
whatever or whatever it is i know this
money doesn't matter to you and i'm like
dude like i'm i'm showing up here the
money matters like you know
please don't not give me the money
because you think it won't matter to me
like you know well i think it does right
so i think that it goes it cuts a little
bit both ways people like i hate the
thing where it's just like dude
thanks so much for taking i know how
busy you are i'm like dude i just like
sit around in my boxes all day like you
know i don't know what i don't know what
you think i'm doing but like my son just
threw up on me like two hours ago this
is awesome compared to that like you
know what do you what do you what do you
think my life is that is so you know so
busy and interesting because it's really
not yeah it is funny when people say
that i'm like well i am busy i'm talking
to people all day but like i don't think
you understand that like talking to just
like slacking back and forth and like
having conversations i remember when me
first started the hustle
like basically these like producers and
this happens all the time these
producers they email just tons of people
who are even remotely interesting and
they're like hey can we make a tv show
about you and obviously like they didn't
know what they're getting into like i'm
not we weren't even remotely interesting
enough but i'm like you guys do realize
we're just sitting in front of a
computer all day right like it's like
the most unfascinating uninteresting
thing it's not interesting at all but uh
dude i'm shocked you don't get like that
uh that uh that that other guy pricing
it's it
you have a b w right
yeah is your house fancy you think or
just normal normal nice my house is not
fancy my house isn't fancy either and
just like i don't know when they like
maybe when they see that like i'm at
home during the day i don't know why but
like i just i'm always nervous i'm like
wait a minute my neighbor's paying only
150 a month for their landscaping why am
i why are you telling me 250. you know
what i mean i feel like that stuff
happens he has a podcast
get your wallet out boys he's got a
podcast
[Laughter]
so whatever i'm past it i got to move
past it
that's so funny you said the thing about
filming by the way i had that same idea
back in the day at monkey inferno
because we had this really nice office
and i thought building startups was the
coolest thing in the world and i was
like why isn't there a documentary crew
here like you know the office but i'm
the cool michael scott right like i'm
awesome and so um you know i had watched
hard knocks on hbo which basically makes
like nfl training camp look like
so epic so like you you start rooting
for these stories all this stuff so i
was like and they have like mics on the
players and you hear like
hey get up get him hey man what you
doing like you hear like them talking
like the pad's hitting you know what i
mean
it's like good yeah but then it also
extends into it's like what you're doing
it's like sorry man i'm just having a
little trouble at home and it's like cue
the music and they cut to the back story
of like you know what's going on at home
and i was like yeah we got these stories
man we're trying to make it into the
rough and tumble world of social media
and i was like you know so it's like i
thought we were cool and then
this like filmmaker type person came to
the office they're like wow incredible
place
um quiet day huh i was like what do you
mean like
normal day he's like everyone's just
sitting there with their headphones on
like not talking to each other like oh
that's what we do all day
he's like well what would we film and i
was like well sometimes we have like a
meeting where we look at the numbers
i guess
yeah i guess you're right we're lame as
hell and so yeah that that is so lame i
i it's always embarrassing when people
like i sometimes our address in the
daily email was in our email and people
would stop by and i'm like
yeah so this is the one room that we sit
down in
there's the bathroom can go to the left
side or the right side you want to see
what it looks like from this corner
just like we just sit here don't talk
sometimes for three hours at a time
there's music playing in the background
every once in a while your office was
hilarious dude it's like why do the dogs
sit in chairs and the people have to sit
on the ground like i love dogs
it's like
why is you know what's going on here why
is there only peanut butter in the
kitchen yeah dude i used to eat like a
jar of peanut butter every two days that
was my step so
then let me tell you this other
interesting thing so
i don't know if you remember this but
there was a that's so funny by the way
you remember the peanut butter i would
eat so much peanut butter we also we
also used to do eating contests once a
month that's like a fun thing because
like we were idiots and we didn't have a
lot of money to like go into a family or
like a team building thing and we would
just go and buy
like 500 burger king chicken mcnuggets
because that's only like 50 bucks and
we'd be like the first person to eat 100
wins which is a horrible idea for dozens
of reasons the first reason being
everyone's sick afterwards it can't work
the second reason being it's just stupid
and the third reason being like no one
does it and they just puke uh and we
would do a crispy cream eating contest a
burger king chicken mcnugget contest
white castle it was the worst i was an
idiot
dude i think these videos still exist
online when i was doing my very first
startup straight out of college which
was like
two buddies doing this stupid sushi
restaurant thing
living in one apartment you know like my
buddy lived in my closet my co-founder
lived in my closet and like you know we
we all we would basically buy air
mattresses and like return them every 90
days to target because we were like oh
you could just like get your money back
is awesome yeah yeah
idiots
totally living the high life with this
and so um basically we
were like i don't know why we were like
you know the way to make our restaurant
you know a restaurant's not open yet but
what can we do that's like our scrappy
mark i don't know why we even thought
this was like remotely relevant we're
like
let's get people invested in the journey
of building this to do that let's create
a youtube channel and we called it the
duel and it was me my friend and the
opening clip is like a high noon like a
standoff like we both walked 15 paces
away turned around and looked at each
other dramatically and it's like the
music's on and then we we would take a
challenge from anybody who commented on
the youtube channel and we would do that
thing and so i was like
oh you're doing a sushi restaurant brush
your teeth with wasabi as toothpaste
for one minute and so we like did it and
then we would it's like you know uh
whatever we did these like really dumb
things you get to see they're like in
this apartment yeah i mean crappy uh
ugly looking kids and it was pretty big
i mean you had literally dozens of
subscribers
i remember we i went out to a casino one
time and my sister was in town and this
guy goes
you're the wasabi guy
and
my sister was like what are you famous
and like i was like what am i famous and
it was like it was like the first hint
of what was you know fast forward 12
years i created the podcast uh like but
in that moment i was like this feels
nice
if i do dumb [__] people will then know
me
and then it ends after that
and all i tacked on later was like and
then i could sell cohort-based courses
that became the the end point but um
anyways long story short i uh if you
remember when clubhouse was popping off
there was this group of also people in
college like people just graduating
college in college that created that
show shoot your shot do you remember
this yeah it was popular like really
popular for four weeks basically and if
i remember correctly it was like three
good looking women and
they would call up a guy and the guy
would hit on him or would the girls make
fun of the guy i forget so they created
a room that was called nyu girls
nyu girls on clubhouse which was already
interesting because clubhouse was just
sf dudes and so you go from sf dudes to
nyu girls that's like a major like you
know
uh you know walking into a a room full
of bears with a pocket full of honey it
was like well what's going on there's
there's interesting people on this app
just like you just imagine a bunch of
like good-looking soho women who hang
out with james franco write poetry and
like you know don't wear bras
like
like that's like it's like stereotype oh
nyuh there's already no bras on
clubhouse but now there's girls with no
problems right so anyways they created
the show and shoot your shot was
basically call up a awkward tech dude
onto the stage and he got to like shoot
his shot kind of like basically like a a
ultra budget version of the bachelors
like come on here and spit game at one
of these girls and we're going to talk
for 20 minutes and we can either boot
you off or we like you and like you're
in the group you you kind of passed the
rite of passage thing a little dating
show and so it started organically but
it got to be like the most popular show
on clubhouse which was you know the
small pawn syndrome right like you were
the best thing in a small little
growing pond
and so anyways it was embarrassing i
listened to i was embarrassed i was like
it was it wasn't bad but i was like oh
they're gonna make fun of them oh don't
make fun of them or like don't say
something stupid guy please like i was
rooting for the men like don't do not to
screw up you know they would get out
they'd be like hey uh you know my name
is uh you know
akbar and you know typical sas guy
and they're like sassy guy and he's like
no like sass like b to be sass
what are you saying
what are these words akbar words
so anyways they do you know what they're
doing now
so the fact that the fact that you said
that phrase about them i'm already on
board like in
yeah
yeah for listening to this somewhere
he's just like there's i could do it
again
like a highlight of my life so
i met the main girl who was behind me i
think her name is devin
and we did a zoom call
you know
she's like what's up nerd
yes and guess what loved it
i did the zoop call you know when you
beat a founder like within sometimes
within 60 seconds you're like all right
you're a star so you're a star that's
established now now i just got to figure
out is this your dumb idea you're kind
of dumb idea or you're a good idea
because you're going to go through
probably all three and i just got to
figure out where you're at in life uh
have you met founders
for sure and it's just like you're
you're not
you're not there yet but i i still am
interested in buying the stock and
getting it i think that's why a lot of
people invested in me at the hustle
same thing with me like i'm like god
people gave us this idea for our sushi
restaurant like you know uh and they
were helping us and they really liked us
like i thought that meant we have a good
business idea and actually what was
happening but now that i'm i'm in that
position i'm like they're just like oh
this guy's gonna do [__] i like this
guy's mojo
this is his dumb idea and like you know
whatever i'm on board to get to the good
idea like i'd like to start this
relationship now yeah so that as he
figures this [__] out you know things
good things happen that's how i felt
about this girl and so she is she's like
an nyu woman like is she like uh that
age yeah she was at nyu and then she
graduated and so now she's like i don't
know shortly out of nyu so she's raised
six million dollars now what
to build um
her show mad reality so the old thing
was nyu girls roast tech guys that's
what the room was called on clubhouse
which was great
and now it's called mad realities and
mad realities they have a it's a
they they went to like web 3 and like
all the stuff right like uh you know i
don't know if you need to do that they
basically gave nfts out to the audience
audience gets to vote it's like the
bachelor but the audience like votes on
what's gonna happen in the show
and so it's a reality show where the
viewers kind of like you know they can
kind of help fork the show and engage
with the plot in some way
and um fans vote them off or whatever
and so they created the show you could
be an nfc holder you get a you're a rose
holder i don't know like they've raised
i think 172 each so what is that today
like at today's prices that's like
250 grand of sales of their nft so not
not huge but you know not terrible but
like the a plus firm in crypto paradigm
um invested in it led the round i think
do they do is their reputation to do
anything that's decent or are they
selective
uh paradigm they're a little mix of both
like
they're the smart guys in the room but i
also think like part of being the smart
guy you know like the smart guy starts
to do weird and crazy [__] and you're
like uh you sure this makes sense and
they're like no it doesn't but that's
why it makes the most sense it's like
all right you know like uh like
founder's friend you just invested in
like i don't know like
this plant that like only causes you to
hallucinate in a bad way they're like
hallucinogens have a bad rap and you're
like all right like in 30 years
hallucinations will be your morning cup
of coffee and you're like i don't think
that's true but you're so smart at
you're good at chess and math so like i
guess i'll just
defer to you on everything in life
that's yeah you you were paypal in 2008
you know what you're doing you know
your hobby is cryptography and you
created paypal so like i guess i'll roll
with you on this like you know kombucha
that you're investing in even though it
doesn't really seem like that big of an
idea so anyways that's kind of what what
i felt like was going on here like
here's their uh investors so paradigm
led it paris hilton uh [__] mccormick
you know like scott belski friend of the
pod uh you know our homie who's super
smart but i think you know when i met
this woman oh
there's like a bunch of names i don't
recognize besides that like you know
probably you know i don't know edm djs
or something people i don't know
maybe
yeah you have to like leave your house
to know these people and say i'm out you
know
the
the um but but i thought this was kind
of interesting like to create a show and
i've actually been i don't think that
this is so two things can't came to mind
one was
when you're a star
you're gonna get funded to do some dumb
[__] and that's okay i actually think
it's a smart idea to like back these
star people because they're gonna do
amazing things in their life as long as
they just keep taking attempts um
i think this is probably not her best
idea but you know three years from now
whatever she's building is probably
going to be amazing i'm on their site
and i'm just skimming through their
videos
i don't know man it seems like they're
executing kind of well on maybe a dumb
idea it seems like a dumb idea but like
my wife is a very smart you know techy
woman and
uh she like is obsessed with the
bachelor or the bachelorette whatever i
don't even know what it is uh like we
have to have we have it in the house i
know i think it's like tuesday at eight
o'clock it's like on and like way to
throw people off your trail there say
the wrong date yeah like you don't sit
down every monday with your with your
glass of rose with sarah and you guys
don't watch this together holding
holding toes
i can't
that'd be weird i i can't stand it all i
know is this season it's two women
picking dudes and i just don't like i i
don't like the thing at all but i know
that it's a huge deal it's still like a
huge deal and my wife sarah is like
talking to all of her friends about it
consistently so like i don't know man
this is kind of a cool idea so it
definitely does seem big and i i
actually do think that you and i don't
know about you but i don't know anything
about the movie business or hollywood or
entertainment i don't know anything
about that and when people talk to me
about like a production company i'm like
what the [__] is a production company
like i don't know what that is but i do
know that reese witherspoon owned one of
them things she owned one of the
production company things and it got
acquired by blackstone for like 500
million dollars like a few months ago
and i do know that uh one of the richest
black men in america i believe his name
is byron allen and uh when i was i was
reading about on wikipedia i wanted to
learn more about what this guy did and
it was like talking about his production
company and all these shows that he made
like damn dude whatever this is it's
actually much bigger and more organized
than i ever even imagined
so it's funny you bring that up i've
been actually in the lab it's not ready
yet but we're gonna take it out for a
spin right now which is i've been in the
lab learning about production companies
and um i'm gonna tell you kind of like
here's the here's my can i give you just
like random rant like it's hard to
understand right normally i have to have
like a package like a take on it that's
what i like to be but you brought it up
so let me give you the unpackaged
unfiltered raw yeah give me that so far
yeah exactly exactly
hey turn the oven down we don't need it
we got a spoon in the dough i want this
content extra gooey
so all right so what's going on so
basically there's streaming wars going
on netflix disney hulu everybody's
fighting for subscribers okay well how
am i going to differentiate from if i'm
netflix how do i differentiate from hulu
and hbo and all this stuff basically
they need original content okay so
that's created this like huge imbalance
of there used to be a lot of content and
a small amount of distribution now
there's a lot of distribution fighting
for a small amount of content and all
the distribution players have just
decided like the prize is big let's lose
money for a lot of like several years
and invest billions into content and
like let's be the last person standing
and so they're they're investing on what
you call a j curve where the curve goes
down you lose a bunch of money and then
a j like a j it goes way up and you make
money later what that means for these
production companies is
they'll overpay there's a bidding war
and they're willing to overpay for my
content and so um so like just last year
basically ruth witherspoon lebron will
smith kevin hart they have sold stakes
in their production companies uh so like
for example kevin hart he has something
called heartbeat he raised a hundred
million from private equity first 15 of
the companies 650 million dollar
valuation kevin
kevin hart 50 of their revenue comes
from the studio arm which they produce
shows for peacock for netflix and uh yes
they make movies and shows explain what
that means so uh they have writers on
staff or writers come to them with an
idea they go this is intriguing we're
gonna pay money
we're gonna pay a hundred or five
hundred thousand dollars we're gonna get
some actors and a set we're gonna make
one or two episodes of this we're gonna
shop it around and then someone will buy
it and we make profit
exactly so i'm gonna use a hollywood
term that i don't know how to use but
i'm gonna just like you know whip it out
here they option it what does that mean
when they option it it's like you know
they basically like it's like they take
an option on the future of this thing
and they basically take you know they
create a sizzle reel or it's like a two
minute teaser or they create a pilot or
they create nothing they just have the
pitch and the concept and you're kevin
hart you go walk into six studios you
say
um it's a movie where
you know me and a tall guy
you know uh we you know we or co-workers
that don't like each other but then we
get trapped in an elevator and they're
like
love it we'll take it you know and
you're like you know how much does it
need it's like we're gonna need a
hundred million dollars to do this of
that you're gonna pay the production
company x millions of dollars to go
produce this movie there's some margin
in that and then um you know they're
gonna and you're gonna
you know whatever the revenue or the
upside would be you know of the project
we're going to have some some split and
presumably
also has other um
you know businesses that that produce so
50 come from the studio arm well what's
the other 50 it's a combination of other
things like content licensing brand
consulting work for companies like png
lyft sam's club stuff like that i don't
know what he's doing but like that's
kevin hart's business but the
value here is presumably kevin hart and
team know about what type of content
gets eyeballs and gets engagement they
presumably have connections with all the
big players and they have some money
that they'll finance things up front and
and and that's they're curators and
operators and they're the influencer so
it's it's like you know everybody kind
of knew hey if you go get an a-list star
you put tom cruise in the movie more
people are going to watch well what
these guys have realized lebron
rhys witherspoon kevin hart
the rock he has his own production
company
what they do what they realize is oh
let's just go vertically integrated like
let's not just be the talent that helps
sell the tickets at box office let's
also be the production company that
creates the thing and then and then what
they don't do is the streaming platform
part they're like okay we'll we'll
partner on that but we're gonna do these
other components ourselves so they're
also you know the big part isn't just
that kevin hart knows what people want
it's like one of the things people want
is kevin hart so he's like cool i'm
gonna own a little more of my upside if
i do this and you know who crushes it
this way
[__] ryan seacrest
i was reading about ryan seacrest and
american idol and this guy that guy is a
workhorse and he has a production uh
company that kills it
yeah you know you know our buddy pomp
pomp is like the ryan seacrest of the
crypto industry
right like he's just everywhere it's
like dude you've got a morning show and
then an afternoon show then you're
producing this thing and then at night
you do this like
wow you your output is unmatched that's
ryan seacrest yeah output is crazy it's
like 20 years i'm on radio for three
hours a morning for 20 years then i do
this then i put on my suit then i host
this then i produced the he produced the
kardashians show yeah and then he's like
uh then i go do american idol and after
american idol i go do this other things
like jeez man like
uh like blink you know
what's going on he's grinding man yeah
that guy kills it
then there's reese witherspoon she sold
her uh company they they made the
morning show which was that big show on
apple tv plus big little lies for hbo
she sold that to candle media which is
basically like a bunch of disney execs
spun off and with like blackstone back
them for like a billion dollars or
whatever and so she sold her
entertainment company to them 900
million she creates shows around women
that's like her shtick and so um
she is awesome i'm a big reese fan reese
witherspoon at brad pitt if you're in it
i go to it
you called a reese witherspoon earlier
and i just thought that was a nice like
touch i never heard that that rendition
before i liked your remix um so so you
know
how much money this just raised
you know how much uh
money her thing made 120 million in 2021
in revenue or price and they expect
revenue um so they expected to double it
to 310 million in 2022 so blackstone
paid like roughly a 7x revenue of where
they bought them they bought um so it's
kind of crazy
and um
so they basically they don't own any
ownership they make the show for the
streaming service
and and then by the way they also when
they bought the company she also has a
book club that's like ridiculous do you
know about her yeah she also has a
clothing brand the clothing brain brand
wasn't a part of it but daper james or
drapper james or something like that
what's it called i don't know dapper
maybe something like that and then she
has a book club it's sunshine something
like hello sunshine book club is that
what it's called i think it's just
called reese's book club uh but it has 2
million followers or members in it i
don't that's like kind of a silly number
um so what she does is she promotes her
favorite books and then what she does is
she goes to those books she's like hey
i'm about to blow your ass up but also i
want the option rights to make a show
out of your book if i can
and so she's like market tests the books
with her book club
makes money there
uses that leverage to get the rights to
that book to make a show out of it then
sells the show rights to the next
girlfriend she's great man she's great
you know like cut throat you know like
media mogul wow like you know innocent
rhys is just like that's an amazing
model
um so yeah i think that's kind of crazy
and also she also sold i think the data
so like um
you know like either like you can
like
the people who bought it i think they
get like you know access to that
membership of the book club and then the
data around them of what they like what
they dislike so long story short this
mad realities thing you kind of just did
the pitch for them where i'm like okay
the macro thing that's as an uneducated
person that's that's mildly interesting
that's a that's an interesting story you
you kind of sold like this actually
could be a huge thing this could be as
big as any other tech company almost so
that's interesting this young woman
doesn't have you know she doesn't have
the clout or connections likely that
rhys or whoever has but like
she's got the charm i buy it
and and the hustle and i think uh if i
was her so here's my brainstorm for her
i think i might have told her this at
some point but uh whatever
i think if i was her i would not be
trying
to create this like standalone show so i
would immediately have been shopping
this i would say hey here's the deal
i can make you the next
too hot to handle love island love is
blind i'm going to make one of these
shows
and
what i would first do is i would build
this i would build the audience on tick
tock or snapchat so i'd first go and
sell it to the social platforms that
also want original cool content for a
small amount of money i'd say hey i'm
going to create cool dating i'm going to
create a dating show on top of tick tock
what's that worth to you guys and
they'll say oh like we'll give you
300 000 or a million dollars out of our
creator fund you know like because tick
tock has i think a 200 million dollar
creator fund right so i'd go to them and
be i'd go get a million million a half
dollars to create the tick tock dating
show
and then i would just take that
popularity and i would say hey netflix
hey whoever
we have the small cult following and we
could build these that you're you know
bachelor these speak to like you know
37 year old women and up or whatever you
know some random yeah i just kind of
pitch it as an older demographic i'd say
you know i can get you this sort of like
14 to 25 year old um dating show
audience because they want this other
thing and like
you know like
and basically create a production
company that's creating dating shows
aimed at my market and try to be the
reese witherspoon of dating reality tv
but i'd be not like doing web 3 crypto
and and doing it on my own website i'd
be going and shopping it to where
there's a whole bunch of buyers and i'm
sure they've they've had conversations i
know that that's not like new to them
but like i think that path can work and
i would just go all in on that path
because i think when you go all in on a
path it's very different than just we've
thought about that or yeah we've had a
couple conversations we've tried it it's
very different than yes i've bet the
whole thing on making that work and come
hell or high water i'm gonna wake up
every morning and figure out how do i go
get hulu to buy this how do i go get
peacock to buy this how do i go get
netflix to buy this and what product do
i need to create that that's my end
customer actually so let me ask you a
practical question that that on on how
easy this is to pull off so
you know who mark manson is mark manson
wrote the book uh the subtle article of
yeah the subtle art i'm not giving a
[__] basically i was like just like i've
hung out with him once or twice and uh
seemed like a really nice guy and i was
just googling like mark manson house and
it said mark manson just sold this
tribeca condo for 15 million dollars and
then i was last year i was reading like
the wall street journal or news corp or
whatever the company that owns uh
penguin publishing his publisher i was
reading all their annual report and they
said mark manson's book like
revolutionized our business so like
clearly this is a 50 billion dollar
company and they're referring to mark
constantly so i'm like wow that that's
amazing and i started researching his
book and
it all stemmed from a blog post he he
launched a blog one blog called this is
the subtle art of not giving a [__] and
he that was a hit and then he took it on
and he uh made it into a book another
guy naval neval had angel list so he was
already successful so it's not exactly
the same thing he had a few interesting
bits of content out there but then he
had this tweet called how to get rich
and it was long tweet storm and it like
kind of was a hit and if he were a
little bit hungrier like mark was then
he could easily parlay that into
something bigger than what it was you
know whatever
when you so you've done this before as
well you've written maybe three
different tweets that like got read
five or tens of millions of times and i
don't know if you would say it was
career changing but like it was like
somewhat trajectory changing i don't
know how big that trajectory is but
let's start at the root level of a tweet
and like with a tv show or a movie or a
broadway show being like the highest
form
if you were given 10 shots and you had
one to two weeks per shot
for a tweet and then let's say maybe a
blog post and then let's say like a
podcast and then let's say a youtube
video how many of those 10 times if you
had a week or so to prepare into
research do you think would become a hit
well there's two versions of a hit a hit
can be
it does well and then there's a hit like
the clubhouse throughout or the
metaverse threat or stuff like that
where it gets to like 20 million people
and like you know like those were hits
those were like i don't know super hits
or grand slams which one do you mean
like the those like absolute bangers or
just like this gets thousands of likes
and gets shared maybe it gets read ten
thousand times or a hundred thousand
times a blog post that gets like well so
let's just say there's friends in
seinfeld and the simpsons and then maybe
there's like
family guy and then maybe there's like
the bachelorette or the bachelor and
then like below that it's like famous
threads yeah
below that what's another tv show that's
like it's like it's actually it's like a
hit but it's like uh like the goldberg
there's like people busking on the
street and below that is your threat
no i mean like look like you know your
version of family guys so far has been
one or two things that you've written
but then you've had like a bunch of like
mild hits so i i think if i the po i
think to answer your question if i tried
the way you said
i think
seven out of ten would like do very well
and then probably
one out of every
ten would be one out of every ten maybe
one out of every twenty yeah it's gonna
say zero to one probably gonna be like a
banger yeah yeah okay so that's just
like a tweet which is like easy ish to
go viral to create um now let's go a
step up a youtube video how many youtube
videos if you had 10 tries do you think
or let's say 20 could be like a hit
honestly i i don't know if i'm gonna
answer your question the way you want
because i kind of think for youtube
videos it's a little easier
i don't know why i think maybe because
we hung out with mr beast and i was like
oh okay i get it like
i get it i get what goes into like i get
what a viral concept would be that
people would click and that they would
share
i get what the hook would be and i get
like you know how to like have the big
payoff the big reveal
um and also i haven't done it so you
know things seem easier when you haven't
done it when you haven't like gone and
tried actually
but i actually think i could have higher
hit rate with youtube videos because you
get editing you get like a whole bunch
of things that go into it compared to a
twitter thread which is very
intellectual like a youtube video you
can like lean on other things to make it
interesting like the visual the like
just literally the fact that it's like a
visual it's a lean back experience
versus like
hey read these 15 tweets and like i hope
i've tickled you like the smart part of
your brain enough or you give a [__] um
so i actually think a youtube video i
think if i try it on youtube i think
seven or eight out of 10 i think would
hit right like in a major way amp it up
you have more time you have a million
plus money
dollars you have a little bit of a team
you have to make a hit show once a
quarter or once every six months or once
a year at most or at least what uh do
you think you could actually come up
with a hit like how hard do you think
coming up with a hit would be
uh
you have more money you've got more time
you have more resources you have to hit
you have to have a hit show and it
doesn't have to be a friends but it has
to be a we're happy that we gave you
money for this and we're going to keep
buying you
how many times out of 10 do you think
you could do that
i think that's lower than the youtube
video for me personally because i'll
tell you the reason why because that's
what we're talking about here
yeah when you do a show you're you're
basically
you bet it all up front and then you
find out way later the feedback loop is
extremely slow compared to youtube
youtube is like i can go from concept to
production to getting the feedback of is
this good or bad within a week
two weeks something like that
and um and so i'm gonna get a bunch of
reps i can try a bunch of different
things and so over the during that
process i'll find a formula that works
whereas with the show it's probably like
i get one one attempt at it ever in life
uh it'll take me like a year to produce
another year to distribute by the time
that's all done whether i was right or
wrong i'm gonna be like
i just hope that i got it right the
first time and so i actually think my
hit rate on a show would be way lower i
think like you know two out of ten or
three out of ten something like that
that's crazy and i answered the way you
thought or no yeah you did and an
interesting exercise i didn't prepare
for this but an interesting exercise is
to think how many game-changing
pieces of content like mark's book
um we'd have to think of a few more
examples we could probably think of a
lot of books um just started with like a
really small thing and they're like oh
that's an interesting vein let's
actually pursue that uh and that's like
an interesting exercise because his book
created tens of millions of dollars
worth of value and it basically
kind of almost on the headline itself
it's kind of a winner and then i'm sure
the blog post which i haven't even read
i'm sure that was actually fire and
amazing but i wonder how many amazing
bits of content have i just started with
a small little rinky dink thing
right i i bet a ton and also i think
for me at least the way i do things i'm
that way where it's like oh cool i want
to write the book let's just tweet out
one tweet all right now five tweets
about that same topic
all right now let's tell them to
subscribe to a newsletter right let's
just see
how much i got what what's resonating
over like for example i'll go look at
any thread if it's 10 tweets i'll go see
which of these has the most likes that's
like not like normally a thread will
just have like kind of like in
descending order like the first we'll
have a lot of likes the last two you'll
have a lot of likes and then it'll just
fall off from there but what you'll find
is when you have a good joke or a good
one line or a good analogy or whatever
that one tweet will get way more likes
and so that's a great way to teach
yourself how to speak better how to
tweet better how to be more compelling
when you do stuff is to like go look at
that and you can do it with other
people's threads too that's what i do i
go look at other people's threads and
i'm sort of looking at oh that's
interesting that one seemed people
really like loved that one liner okay
that's that's cool i like how they did
that that's i can pick that up for my
game that's crazy yeah by the way one
one other numbers here so lebron's
production company 45 million in 2020 uh
revenue
revenue 100 million in 2021 and um they
basically do the same thing but they do
a bunch of stuff so they have
uh like uninterrupted which is videos
and like it's good i like it uh they
also have like merchandise apparel
there's like a clothing brand then they
have the hbo series the shop then they
made the new space jam movie and so his
company spring hill uh basically created
a bunch of these and they did the same
thing they went and sold it to others if
i was these guys on if i'm if i'm lebron
and i have so much income coming from
other things i would play a really long
game because i think that
going and selling the shop to hbo like
the shop is actually a pretty dope show
it's like this barbershop and they get
like you know whatever whoever big
actors nfl players players just shooting
the [__] in a barbershop setting and
it's like really high quality
it's great it's kind of like mfm but
famous people who are more interesting
better and getting haircuts yeah take
what you see now yeah
trim my beard first of all secondly
we're more athletic more successful
funnier
cool you know
all right so so basically that show is
awesome but how many of lebron's fans
right lebron's fans are like mostly
younger people
like you know that's like if you're an
nba star your fans go from like you know
eight years old on up they don't have
hbo
and so it's like if i'm him why am i not
playing the long game jeff bezos style
and just saying i'm gonna drop this dope
premium content on
uh youtube tiktok instagram whatever
and
i'm gonna put the whole thing here i'm
gonna blow normal content out of the
water here because i'm bringing
production budgets to this
and actually i'm going to invest like
what michael jordan did with his like
uh the last dance like the last dance
like documentary it's like i'm going to
invest a lot of money but i'm not going
to like put it behind like netflix is
okay because it's a paywall a lot of
people have
um but i would just put it on youtube
and i would basically bet that if i grow
my brand and my legacy
through
this content um
there's a bigger payoff than what the
streaming companies are going to pay me
today
and i would be willing to invest 20 30
50 million dollars
in order to build like a billion dollar
plus type of brand payoff at the end
because
you will just be like you know worshiped
and adored even more than you already
are and so you know you want to go on
one end of the spectrum or the other you
want to go like
i'm getting paid a stupid amount of
money and it doesn't really matter how
many people watch this or i want
everybody to watch this and i'll pay
money to get it there because there's a
bigger payoff for me outside of that you
know like the logan paul method where
it's like
everything's free everything's on
youtube
i'm in your face
and then i'll launch my like energy
drink and i think their energy drink
does like some stupid number like it's
doing really well like 100 million
dollars a year or something like well i
i i don't know the exact number i heard
about on the pod they were talking about
how they did 10 like i think it was
around 10 million in month one of sales
um but i actually think that the that
drink business um if like mr beast has a
40 chocolate business i'm curious if
some of these low ticket items can
actually become like legitimately
great companies as opposed to just okay
uh i think it's hard to sell a two
dollar drink uh and make it like work
really well so we'll see if they'll make
it work but but dude all these water
companies do amazing
but many don't obviously i mean many
times but if you got the distribution
right like why is mr beast not doing
beast water
because he can basically pair it with
like you know like that boxed water
thing where it's like this is better for
the earth yeah it's like mr beast likes
that [__] where he's just like oh we're
gonna plant a billion trees
and the way we're gonna plant billion
trees is by not doing plastic water
bottles all right everybody join me
this is mr beast you know aluminum cans
sparkling water like go [__] lacroix up
all right like go go [__] these guys up
like
mr beast could destroy these guys right
uh you know like beast water like
go into the things go go make products
that everybody on earth consumes
because you're the mainstream like
content maker right so it's like dude
when he when he had the chocolate i was
like damn dude i want to like eat this
chocolate because i want to like you
know show you like appreciation for like
being here and you brought your item and
like yeah sure i'll eat some of it but i
felt so bad eating it because i don't
like eating that type of stuff i mean
i don't eat a chocolate bar on a daily
basis well i yeah and i love it and i'm
sorry i thought eating it i was like i
don't want to eat this but i want to be
respectful and kind and because he
brought this thing and i was like dude
you need to make something different
that i that that i like can consume
guilt-free i don't know that many people
that just eat chocolate like a like a
hershey's chocolate bar you know what i
mean
you're correct in fact that's a filter i
have if i ever just see you just eating
a chocolate bar on a tuesday like i'm
going to begin to distance myself right
like i'm trying to be around a certain
type of person that's like you know
healthier
come to think about it i don't know
anybody that doesn't actually you know
funny story uh
when i joined monkey inferno i was like
um
so what was it like the last product
manager the la the guy so i joined as a
pm product manager the guy who was there
before me was this guy alex too who
created a million-dollar homepage back
in the day and now is the founder of
calm like a multi-billion dollar company
he was the boss of monkey inferno not
the boss he was he was like the product
manager so he was the product manager
there he quit to go start calm
and um they were like i was like oh
how's alex like you know i love that
guy's work like you know millionaire
homepage is dope calm interesting like
meditation is he just like super zen or
what like is he huge on meditation
they're like
you know that's the funny thing
they're like i think he needs calm i
wouldn't say he is calm i was like what
do you mean like you know alex is a fun
time dude he's like he loves to hang he
likes to go out like he loves to have
drinks like you know he's just like a
young dude like in his 20s in a big city
like you know he's he's not like waking
up every morning going to his japanese
like you know you know
garden and just like sitting there for
eight hours just you know contemplating
you know the thoughts in his mind and so
i was like what's the crate what's the
most degenerate thing i was like give me
a story what's degenerate thing the
founder of calm is down they go
i remember one time he came in and he
was kind of hung over and he just got a
bowl like you know for cereal like his
office had like a kitchen he's like but
instead of cereal he just went put a
bunch of m ms in there with a spoon and
just ate it
i was like i don't know if this story is
true or false but it's hilarious and i'm
running with it
that's awesome
i remember thinking at that time if calm
ever becomes a thing i'm always gonna
remember that you know like
you know that story there's like one of
these like hilarious small small stories
he's a d-gen just like us
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
when we had our office
i remember i was having a bad day and
when i had bad days i like to like
punish myself by eating poorly you know
it's like that's like my version of just
like drinking a 12 pack
and i it was me and my writer connor
were still in the office at like 8 p.m
and i was like connor today sucked i was
like i looked at him i go
i bet you i can eat this whole jar of
unopened skippy in three bites
and i did
and i did and i felt so horrible for
like three days and so that was my that
was my dj
diet moment was just eating an entire
jar of skippy peanut butter in 30
seconds
that's crazy um all right let me give
you
the thing i'm currently obsessed with so
the thing i'm currently obsessed with i
brought this up maybe three four times
people may be sick of this by time by
now
but i feel like no one is talking about
it i feel like not enough people
are freaking out about what's going on
with artificial intelligence for
creating art
so uh we've talked about this before
uh there's gpt3 which is basically ai
that will write something for you so you
could just give it a prompt it'll write
the essay there's dali where you just uh
type in a thing it'll generate images
like as if you searched it on google
but i now have like a bigger picture
view of this which is
you know like
in the early days of the web the big
winner was search engines yeah so
you know google obviously was like a
search engine because it's like oh the
internet basically technology's now put
a bunch of information out there so we
need a search engine to basically find
the thing we want
now what's happening is you have a
generation engine right a generative
engine is you go search for the thing
and it creates it for you right so it's
like
it's
that's just like right there is like a
mind-blowing concept instead of
searching the internet for a thing that
might be out there what's the closest
thing to what i want it's just to say
i i have basically the genie from
aladdin and i can go say
play me a song that mixes like kind of
like beethoven and kanye
but it's about you know taking mushrooms
and literally ai will just create a song
and guess what it doesn't suck
and to me this is so insane this is so
mind-blowing every demo i see i'm just
like
i drop immediately what i'm doing i'm
like well what i'm doing is stupid like
oh like cool a podcast you know like oh
what
am i doing like talking to my mother who
cares about my mother there's a.i that
can create [__] that you just like spit
out of your mouth and so i think
i really just want to go down this
rabbit hole and figure out what all this
is going to be going to be able to do so
now there's this new thing called stable
diffusion have you seen this one no
stable diffusion's the new demo that
came out unlike dolly they basically
they didn't like kind of pay wall it
and so anybody can go and use it and you
just type in a prompt so you're like
like go to the subreddit stabled so go
to stable
diffusion subreddit
uh just to see like what people create
so it's r
stable diffusion so just look at the top
thing right so um i look at like
um
let me show you a good one okay go to
the one that says wendy's do you see it
like scroll down maybe top from one
today or it's hot
i just like normal sorting so hot and
then go down five and just look at
wendy's oh yeah oh my god
and this is awesome so how does this
work so basically you just type in like
the prompt right so um the prompt that
he gave was a beautiful portrait of
wendy's mascot intricate elegant elegant
and highly detailed and then it just
creates
this like beautiful redheaded girl
holding a burger with fries and it's
like
it looks like this incredible art
and um and so you could just and then
you you could just you just hit the
dream but that was the button like you
know the google button is like search or
i'm feeling lucky the one on this says
dream and you hit dream and it just
it'll just morph it it'll morph it it'll
morph it it'll morph it'll morph it'll
just keep making new ones
instantaneously it's like working with a
designer it's like try again give me
something else no not that okay make it
blue and it'll just instantaneously
recreate something incredible uh right
then right so it's like
um it's it's just mind-blowing what it's
creating and then you can see these
videos so go down uh just do like a ctrl
f and uh write the words preview of next
feature
um and it's a picture of a duck
yeah it's a picture of a duck and it's
like
it looks like a guy in photoshop or
paint making a duck right so he's he's
in i think i think it's photoshopped as
the actual tool but uh
it looks like a microsoft paint duck so
it's just like a yellow blob with an
orange little duckbill right all right
so it's a two minute video what he's
showing is he created a photoshop plugin
using stable diffusion that lets you
draw anything crappy
and then you just run the plugin and
watch get to the end so like go all the
way to the end and so he just adds a
little blue and so by the end you see
this basically like this like fancy
looking duck wearing a monocle
and like a blue like tuxedo shirt and
it's like the sophisticated ass duck
dude if i'm a web designer i'm freaking
out right now
hey we thought ai would like you know uh
it's going to automate the shitty jobs
it's like actually it's coming for your
throat artist like
dude so i i've been i followed this guy
i've been looking for his name i found
him his name is lou yah so l-o-u-y-a-h
and i follow him on tick-tock and what
he does is every once in a while he'll
have a post where he
he's a producer and he'll be like here's
a rap country song that doesn't exist
and he makes a song
and they sound great and he's he's done
this a bunch of times and um
martin shkreli in one of his blog posts
he said when i was in prison i had a lot
of time to think here's a bunch of
predictions that i have for the next 100
years as well as timelines so one of his
predictions he'll be like we're going to
land on mars by 2050 or whatever and
another prediction is
a artificially made song is going to be
in the top
10 most played songs in the world and on
billboard top 10 inside the next 18
months like he put a time limit on it
and i and i'm on board with that i 100
believe in that i 100 believe in that
and i don't get
why more people aren't freaking out
there are obviously pockets of people
who really are really interested in this
people see the demo but like
it's kind of like um we just passed up a
purple unicorn while we were driving on
a road trip it's like oh wow barbara
unicorn and we just like okay uh you
guys want to stop at wendy's and it's
like
dude wait hold on there was a purple
unicorn next to the road like pull over
what are we doing like i think everybody
needs to pull over and be like what the
hell is happening this is gonna like
this is so insane to me um
and i just feel like these idea like
there's gonna be a google-like company
that's not a search engine it's a
generation engine it's a dream engine
you're gonna go there you're gonna say
what you wish i think somebody's gonna
make this for kids like i was like dude
i could make i didn't i told you before
i was like i'm interested in creating
like a pixar like company but it's like
why would i create one movie what if i
created an app that my daughter could
just talk to no no text input she can't
type she just could say a duck surfing
you know with an ipad and like you know
holding an ipad and like she could just
say any words and this thing would
create not only an image but it could
create an animation it could create a
set of animations it could create a
whole story
based off that she could create her own
movie just by saying
you know a boy who loves soccer but he's
sad because he doesn't get enough
chocolate and it would create
you know a movie based on that it would
create a portrait based on that and like
she could create art just with her
imagination
to me is wild have you ever heard this
theory that your words shape your
thoughts and it's not just like positive
thinking it's like literally if that if
a word that doesn't describe a
particular type of feeling exists in
your language then it's hard for you to
have that feeling so this particular
example isn't exactly proven to be true
and a lot of people debate it but there
was a
group of africans who didn't have like
the perfect word for square or like a 90
degree angle and all of their homes were
in circles they were like circled and so
they didn't they for some reason like
the idea of like square and 90 degrees
it just wasn't part of their their
language and so everything a lot of
items in their in their culture were
circles or uh there's like terms for
like you know i'm feeling depressed but
i'm not suicidal or something in like a
different country and like that's like a
better word sometimes than like
depressed and so people are like oh you
know i'm just in this mood and they can
explain it a little bit better and they
feel that way and and it's almost like
explaining to a blind person like hey
tell me what red looks like it's like i
don't know i can't i can't explain what
that is when i'm it's too hard i don't
have that my vocabulary with something
like this i wonder if there's if it will
unlock like a new way of storytelling or
a new way of seeing art and it will
actually could actually change our our
mindset on a lot of different things
because like if you
if you if you want to make a movie now i
mean you're going to be influenced by
everything that exists and then
occasionally someone's going to come and
do something totally mind-break
mind-changing and that one person is
like kind of once-in-a-generation type
of person and they just like are really
unique like a steve jobs but when you
have something that is collectively
aggregating all of the data in the world
that has ever existed and then coming up
with something interesting do you know
what i mean like right i wonder what
like the the the that's how i've been
thinking about it like man well the new
stuff that this thing can come out with
i can't i literally can't think of you
know what i mean totally because what
they do is they train it on like just
you know they basically go scrape
gigabytes and gigabytes and gigabytes of
images from the web and they basically
there's a big controversy around that
some people are like that's unethical
those people who put their images up on
the web they didn't know it was gonna be
it was gonna be used to train ai that
was going to then put them out of work
like that's you know that's not so great
but like
and by the way there's like a name for
this some people are trying to do vegan
ai
you know what that is no but that's
awesome vegan ai is basically ai that's
trained only on non-copyright written
work so it's like like worked out images
that were like uh intentionally said to
be royalty free out there for public use
out there for use it however you want
um it's like if it was only trained on
that it's sort of like grass-fed well
right what's like a perfect example of
this and like is the ultimate villain
move is github which is a website that
uh developers post code on it's almost
like uh it's part practicality they post
code so you could share it but they also
like it's like a portfolio almost and
what github is doing which is owned by
microsoft at this point i think they are
basically like using ai to scan all the
best code of all the code that has ever
been uploaded and you can kind of like
am i explaining this right you can
they've using ai to write new code based
off of all the users who have input data
and the users are like oh cool so you're
taking our portfolio you're and you're
going to use it to put us out of work
that that's nice
right
yeah and uh and i think nat freeman who
is the
i think he was this i feel like he was
the ceo of github for a period of time i
don't know if he still is but he just
tweeted out he goes
the 10 billion dollar ai first product
idea hiding in plain sight is github
co-pilot which is the name of the thing
you said right like the ai assistant
that helps you write your code for
customer support
you can fine-tune it basically you have
this archive of all of your thousands
and thousands of company like uh tickets
that were like resolved like resolved
customer support issues um
and your support rep who's just like you
know random person sitting in you know
maybe the philippines or something like
that gets dramatically more productive
and your customers get better and like
training becomes easier because
you have any company with 20 support 20
or more support reps he says you know
would buy this and um and and so you
know like
that guy basically like i think co-pilot
is like a billion dollar a year
add-on to a billion more than a billion
dollar a year add-on now for github
because so many software developers opt
into it because it makes them more
productive so it's like how many other
areas uh is that going to happen to you
dude
when we discuss this i'm like this is
this is the type of like macro movement
that it's like dude just quit what
you're doing and just
join get in somehow you know almost yeah
i don't really like crypto but almost
like crypto in like 09 or 11 or
something like that or uh it's like i
don't know man it's kind of hard to miss
if you're just kind of in the in the in
the ballpark 100 100 that's how i feel
about this like that's wait we drove by
a purple unicorn pull over the car pull
over the car in your career and
basically go dive in and figure out what
this is and if people are already driven
in tell me because i'm trying to dive in
i want to learn as much as i can about
this over the next six months because i
find it fascinating i'm gonna i can't
show this graph but i'm just gonna tell
you a graph real quick all right
there is a company
i wonder if i could say the name i'm
gonna say the name maybe we have to
bleep this out later so there's a
company called have you heard of this
yeah
i don't exactly know what they do but uh
they're basically like an i think
they're just like an ai copywriting
solution that's another website just you
know
they're they based out of austin i think
i met the founder actually
so sounds cute right oh you know ai
helps you copyright copywriting is this
little niche thing that you and i are
wearing we help people with copywriting
to we both have like a copyrighted
course or product like that
here's their annual recurring revenue
january of 2021
january 2.5 million
that that's their annual recurring
this is their error uh rate that they
were at so
um january january 2001 two and a half
million that's pretty good like congrats
um fast forward to april 5.7 million oh
wow you guys doubled in four months like
really great progress i'm super
impressed like you guys this you guys
are probably onto something this could
be like a
100 million company or something like
that
fast forward to july 20 million dollar
run rate
oh wow what's going on it's one year
you've gone from 2.5 to 20 million
fast forward to october 40 million
it's like what is happening in one year
this went from two and a half million to
40 million dollar run rate
that is absolute insanity to me i've
i've never seen an ar chart like that
now i don't know how did you get super
legit
uh someone shared it with me so you know
i don't know how legit this is but um
i don't think it's fake you know uh
it's crazy to me so but it's just like
kind of a mind-blowing level of traction
god damn yeah i'm on board with this
stuff this is pretty cool that's insane
i can't believe how big that is wow it
seems almost too good to be true all
right anything else that we wanted to
cover
no that's the pod
[Music]
you